this morning the leader of the Oath
Keepers a far-right political group is
facing many years in prison
Stuart Rhodes and other members of the
group were convicted of multiple charges
by Washington D.C jury yesterday they
were accused of plotting The Assault on
the capitol Scott McFarland is outside
the federal courthouse in Washington
Scott good morning I hear that rain in
the background
yeah naked morning nearly two years
after the attack a jury is convicted
five members of the far-right oath
Creepers on federal charges including
the founder Stewart Rhodes on a Civil
War era charge of seditious conspiracy
applauding to block the peaceful
transfer of power in America
it was a marathon two-month-long trial
involving Stuart Rhodes founder of the
far right Oath Keepers the most high
profile figure to date to face charges
in connection with the deadly January
6th ride
prosecutors showed messages and images
of The Oath Keepers hatching a plan to
equip themselves with tactical gear and
to Stage guns outside the Washington DC
city limits to mobilize if then
president Trump invoked the Insurrection
act he was responding to things that the
former president was saying that makes
it a Titanic event that will be surely
in the history books this this
conviction for seditious conspiracy
prosecutors also argued Rhodes talked of
Civil War and was the architect of a
plan that included some members of The
Oath Keepers breaching the capital in a
military stack formation it was all laid
out in audio presented at trial
[Music]
Rhodes took the stand that his own
defense arguing the group brought gear
because they feared being targeted by
left-wing agitators but he didn't sway
the federal jury but convicted both
roads and a top Deputy co-defendant
Kelly Megs on multiple counts including
seditious conspiracy Mercy each man
facing up to 20 years in prison on that
charge alone the jurors found three
other oath keeper co-defendants not
guilty of seditious conspiracy but
convicted them on other federal charges
defense attorneys told CBS news they
planned to appeal it goes without
question we're disappointed
a conviction for seditious conspiracy
isn't just rare the Department of
Justice hasn't won one in nearly 30
years and several other accused
far-right group members face trial of
that same charge in the coming weeks and
Gail one of those trials will likely be
underway here January 6 2023.
hmm y'all remember that date that
verdict says a lot thank you very much
Scott